l'ol il ya un surf voilà ici qui a été
installé au quai où normalement quand je
dis un surf hashtags acheteurs et on va
faire défiler les chroniqueurs pour voir
qui a le meilleur style sur du sort
ok et je l'aï alors alors tu peux coller
à ce que tu viens pas si vous voulez
aller la tête haute et je veux qu'on
avait avec elle à déchets comme les
filles sont ouverts à bombay manille
alors là lawani honeywell
ouais
[Musique]
voilà
je vais envoyer le premier candidat
c'est la jambe arrière on est comme ceux
ci la jambe arrière il fut l'ischio
jambier chez vous comme ceux ci on est
quand même sinon tu mara 31 janvier des
autres la facturation des alémaniques
[Rires]
sans ça ça va pas durer longtemps c'est
un peu de mal à les bouger c'est pas mal
mais jean michel jean millet vais
arrêter là la planche est déjà très
agitée à guédiawaye balla il a un style
ou alors juste titre et bien je sais ce
que tu fais pour mes intérêts tube tu
glisses ton oignons soir ballack est
gogo
[Applaudissements]
on va demander à castres je sois pas
trop fan j'ai bien sûr pas trop fort
geoffrey rosso en fait mais ce parce
qu'on aime ça là c'est franchement
sautant sur la planche il aussi long que
ces mariages
réponse oui merci
basile catherine ont montré de très
belles choses cette base ils m'ont dit
oh la la à lévis la tension retombe sur
valeurs et du baril vêtus en or qui
varient
à
le prénom du chroniqueur et on va
désigner les prix de 20 sur browse ça va
merci
elle est allée voir le docteur bakary
berthé allez c'est bon
merci bakiev à de graves tensions
voilà les îles à l'arrière des mois la
presse voulait pas ça y est vous mettrez
habitués les chairs et venaient tous à
donner tout cela lors ils venaient tous
abonnés vont mal avec marek malik et qui
est là qu'elle a aujourd'hui sa monture
et fils m'a fait essayer parce que
j'aime mon pays parce qu'il fallait pas
cassé la porte ce nom me dis pourquoi
j'étais magnifique pour certains
venaient là venez là venez venez tout
cela venait tout cela parce que
maintenant on va procéder à la remise du
dossier je vais demander
actuellement la vente partout où je vais
demander pour la médaille de bronze et
une petite voix côtés de sofia pour la
les dates de leur tournée à paris élu
médaille de bronze s'il vous plaît
olivier est ce qu'on peut me le dire
dans l'oreillette
personne ne me dit rien dans
l'oreillette qui a été élue médaille de
bronze
la médaille de bronze les chéris alors
surprise générale franchement non je
cours pour moi la médaille de bronze
c'est jean michel maire
poitiers potes à foison par bojan me
voilà tout la médaille est ravi la
médaille d'argent
la médaille d'argent les chéris elle et
elle est la médaille d'argent
pour isabelle morel voilà bravo fait la
prostate une peine infinie baume le
temps me donnez moi la machine et on a
l'air et la médaille d'or les chéris
damilano chômage et donc tu sers la
médaille d'or était strip ans c est bien
sûr notre ami doc gynéco fait une pause
bravo tu as gagné et les séries le
public a décidé aussi de décerner une
médaille d'honneur à une personne ici
voilà une médaille d'honneur vient
d'arriver chez rivétoile à une médaille
d'honneur c'est pour vous magali merci
beaucoup
magali à lisier mais c'est vous sur le
photocall et voilà magali est ce que
vous avez dit ce qu'on va faire
alors regarder la caméra la caméra la
merci à tous suis ravi et franchement et
vous savez ce que c'est que cette
médaille c'est la médaille d'honneur
c'est une médaille en chocolat
chez toi